ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนทุกคน
ก็วันนี้กลับมาเจอกับเรา 2 คนในวีดีโอ
ระดับอะไรคะวีดีโอระดับบีกินเนอร์ค่ะกิน
อาหารดีกินได้ Class ไทยแล้วค่ะครูฟ้าคะ
วันนี้วันพละย
วันนี้วันอังคารค่ะวันนี้วันอังคารนะคะ
วันอังคารที่เท่าไหร่คะวันอังคารที่ 30
อาร์มเรียนอะไรคะเดือน
พฤศจิกายนเดือนพฤศจิกายนเป็นเดือนที่เท่า
ไหร่
เดือนพฤศจิกามีคนเป็นเดือนที่ 11 ค่ะ
11 ปีพตอะไรคะดีพ.ต.ต.
2564  a คศอะไรคะปีค.ศ
2002  1 ห่าง
เมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะครูป๊า
เมื่อวานนี้วันจันทร์ฉัวันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่
29 ค่ะดีเดือนเดือนพฤศจิกายนเป็นเดือน
ที่เท่าไหร่คะเป็นเดือนที่ 11 ค่ะตีผชปี
พ.ศ 2556  4 ปีคศ 2  021
พรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะพรุ่งนี้วันพุธที่หาวัน
พุธที่ตัวเท่าไหร่คะวันพุธที่ 1  2 ก็
เดือน
ธันวาคมค่ะเอา
เปลี่ยนเดือนเนาะไม่ใช่เดือน
พฤศจิกายนเปลี่ยนเป็นเดือนธันวาคมแล้ว
เดือนธันวาคมเป็นเดือนที่เท่าไหร่คะเดือน
ธันวาคมเป็นเดือนที่ 12 หากปีพตตปีพต 2
564 ปีค.ศต้ด
นะก็วันนี้วันนี้วันอังคารแล้วแล้ว
ตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงแล้วคะคุณฟ้า
ตอนนี้เวลา
10:00 น 10 โมงกี่นาทีคะ
35 นาทีค่ะ 325 อันนี้ 10 โมง 35 นาที
แล้ว
ตอนเช้าใส่ค่ะเป็นตอนเช้าแล้วโครงฟ้าผู้
หญิงนักเรียนทุกคนตื่นแล้วตื่นแล้วค่ะใส่
ข้าวเช้าหรือยังคะผู้หญิงกินข้าวเช้าแล้ว
ค่ะกินแล้วนะครูฟ้าราคา
รูปฟ้าก็ก็กินข้าวเช้าแล้วหากินข้าวเช้า
กินแล้วเลยเอา
ครูฟ้ากินอะไรคะ
ครูฟ้า yet  in
pang หาเครย์ตอนเช้าครูฟ้ากินขนมปัง
ชายอันนี้มี
ขนมปังขนมปัง
เผือกอะมีขนมปังขนมปังเผือกมีทั้งกิน
นี้เอาอ๋อ
แล้วให้ครูฟ้าอันนี้เป็นขนมปังใช่ไหมคะ
ขนมปังเนาะครูฟ้าเนี่ยทาอะไรที่ขนมปังไหม
คะ
ทาอะไรหรอคะ
กูฟ้าทานูเทร่า
เป็นช็อกโกแลตเนาะหนู Tara นะช็อกโกแลต
นักเรียนผ้าช็อกโกแลตมือเซราบนขนมปัง
บนเขาฟัง
แล้วคุยฟ้ากินขนมปังเมื่อไหร่
คู่ฟ้ากินขนมเลือกตั้งก่อน
9:30 นน
และครูฟ้ากินขนมปังตอน
9:30 นถึง
[เพลง]
แล้วครูฟ้ากินขนมปัง
กับใครสมัครนี้มีครูฟ้า
ครูฟ้า
แล้วก็คนนี้
ครูฟ้ากินขนมปังกับใคร
กูฟ้ากินขนมปังกับคุณแม่ค่ะเอานี่กูฝาใช่
ไหมฝาเราก็มีคุณพ่อคุณแม่คนนี้ใช่ไหมคุณ
แม่
กินขนมปังกับคุณแม่ค่ะแล้วครูป๊ากินคือ
ขนมปัง
ขนมปังเนี่ยนะขนมปังกับคุณแม่กูฟ้ากิน
กี่ชิ้นขนมปังเนี่ยกี่ปีนี่
รูปฟ้ากินขนมปัง 5 ชิ้นค่ะโห
ชิ้นหรือ 5 แผ่นเนาะมาก Can  Can  Store
1  2 หลังสี่ห้าใช่มั้ยฮะไม่
แล้วคุณแม่เหรอคุณแม่กินขนมปังกี่แผ่นคุณ
แม่กินขนมปัง 1 แผ่นค่ะคุณแม่หนึ่งครูฟ้า
อ้าว
สุภชอบกินหนูและล่ามาก
แล้วครูฟ้าใช่ไหมคะจับคุณแม่แม่กินขนมปัง
ที่ไหนเนื้อ
เพลงที่ไหน
in ที่บ้านตรง
[เพลง]
ที่บ้านยิ่งที่บ้าน
บ้านครูฟ้า
บ้านครูปลาค่ะกินที่
ห้องนั่งเล่นอ๋อนี้ที่บ้านใช่ไหมล่ะแล้ว
ก็ทำซุ้มสวยห้องนั่งเล่นก็จะมีทีวี
ก็มีอะไรเนี่ย R
อะไรคะศพ
ผู้หญิงก็ว่าลูกเก่งมากนะคะนักเรียน
ประมาณนี้ไหม
มันเป็นโซฟาหนังโซฟาทีวีแล้วก็จะมีโต๊ะ
เล็กนึง 1 ตัวหรอเอาครูฟ้ากินขนมปังที่
บ้านในห้องนั่งเล่นโอ๊ยตายในห้องนั่งเล่น
นะฮะๆๆคุณแม่ทำแน่ฉาครั้ง
แล้วผู้หญิงล่ะผู้หญิงกินอะไรคะวันนี้
สมัครคุยกินก๋วยเตี๋ยวค่ะครูฟ้า
อ๋อกินก๋วยเตี๋ยวจ้าซ้าย
ก๋วยเตี๋ยว
ก๋วยเตี๋ยวลูกชิ้นหมูไม่เป็นก๋วยเตี๋ยว
แล้วก็มีลูกชิ้นนะเป็นลูกชิ้นหมู
เหต่ายขา
ก๋วยเตี๋ยว
เส้น
ก๋วยเตี๋ยวจะมีอันนี้อะไรเหล่มีเส้นใช่
ไหมเส้นก๋วยเตี๋ยวผู้หญิงกินก๋วยเตี๋ยว
เส้นอะไรคะ
มีผู้หญิงกินก๋วยเตี๋ยวเส้นบะหมี่ค่ะ
เส้นบางที
สีเหลืองใช่ลมถูกน้าอาแล้วกินตอนกี่โมงฮะ
ผู้หญิงกินก๋วยเตี๋ยวตอนอ่า
8:00 น
45 นาทีค่ะ
8:40 นประมาณเนาะ
ประมาณ 8 โมง 45 นาทีน
กินก๋วยเตี๋ยวแค่ 100 หรอ
ใช่กิน When
My  Mind กินก๋วยเตี๋ยวอย่างเดียวตอน
เช้า
ดื่มน้ำไว้ฮะอ๋อผู้หญิงดื่มดื่มน้ำค่ะ
ก็จะเป็นอ่า
ต่อไปนี้น้ำเปล่าน้ำเปล่าเราจะไปเทแล้วก็
ใส่แก้วมีน้ำแข็งด้วยนะกูฟ้า
น้ำเย็นนะมีได้
น้ำเย็น
ก๋วยเตี๋ยวเนี่ยร้อนก็ดื่มน้ำเย็น
โหดีมากค่ะแล้วครูหญิงกินก๋วยเตี๋ยวที่
ไหนคะผู้หญิงกินก๋วยเตี๋ยวที่ร้าน
ก๋วยเตี๋ยว
[เพลง]
เตี๋ยวปลูกฟ้าเนี่ยกินที่บ้านสมัยกรุงฟ้า
กินก๋วยเตี๋ยวที่บ้านแต่คุยเนี่ยไม่ได้
ให้ความไม่ได้กินก๋วยเตี๋ยวผู้หญิงเนี่ย
ไม่ได้กินก๋วยเตี๋ยวที่บ้านน้องฟ้ากินขนม
ปังที่บ้านได้ดูโทรหาแม่กินอ่ะลิงกิน
ก๋วยเตี๋ยวที่
ร้านก๋วยเตี๋ยวค่ะพี่น้องเป็นร้านใช่ไหม
เป็นร้านใครขนาด
Open อะไรคะเขามีตีมึงกับกูฟ้าน้องควีน
นี่ดิใช่ไหมจี้
ร้านก๋วยเตี๋ยวไหมก็จะมีแม่ค้าทำ
ก๋วยเตี๋ยวเป็นสิ่งที่ร้านก๋วยเตี๋ยวค่ะ
ร้านก๋วยเตี๋ยวดีว่าผู้หญิงไปกินกับใครฮะ
ผู้หญิงไปคนเดียวอยากครูหญิงคนเดียว
กินคนเดียว
[เพลง]
ร้าน
อะไรบาสเตียเขียวเนี่ย
อยู่ไกลไหมคะน้อไม่ไกลจะไหมอันนี้เนี่ย
คอนโดมิเนียมเรา
Condominium ผู้หญิงใช่ไหมคะแล้วก็ถนน
ตรงนี้
ร้านก๋วยเตี๋ยวเนี่ยถ้าคุยหนิงเดินน้อง
เดินๆไปก็ประมาณ
คือ 3 นาที
เดินประมาณ 3
3 นาทีก็ถึงร้านก๋วยเตี๋ยว
ใกล้ๆ
อื่นโอเคใช่มั้ยเดินโอเคแล้วครูฟ้าอ่ะ
เนี่ยกินขนมปังใช่ไหมคะแล้วครูฟ้าดื่ม
อะไรไหม
ครูฟ้าดื่มนมหะหนูครูฟ้าดื่มนมตายเป็นเอา
นมอะไร
นมกันแล้วนมซองเบอร์รี่
เป็นนมตราหมีอะอ๋อ
เรารูปอยู่นี่นมตราหมี
r&d มนมใช่หายในนมแล้วครูฟ้าดื่มนมตอน
เวลากี่โมงคะ
ผู้ฟ้าดื่มนมตอนเวลา
10:00 นค่ะอ๋อ
หลัง 10:00 น
10:00 นนะดื่มนมได้อ้วกผู้บ่าวหนุ่มไป
ฟรีซไว้นะหรือ
Freeze ร้อนแล้วค่อยดื่มก็มันให้มันเย็น
ๆไหมคบฟรีซแล้วมันก็จะเย็นแล้วก็ไปดื่มนม
ครูฟ้าดื่มนม
ที่บ้านมีพระที่บ้าน
ใช่ไหมคะ
ใช่หาครูฟ้าดื่มนมที่บ้าน
แต่คุยฟ้าดื่มนมในห้องนอน
ไม่ใช่ห้องดูทีวี
กันห้องรอนห้องนอนก็จะมีเตียงนอน
ห้องนอนครูฟ้าดื่มนมที่ห้องนอนที่ห้อง
ดื่มคนเดียวหรือว่าดื่มกับคุณแม่
ครูฟ้าดื่มนมคนเดียวอ่ะ
รู้ฟ้าคนเดียวเนาะคุณพ่อคุณแม่ไม่ใช่ครู
ฟ้าคนเดียว
[เพลง]
เมื่อดื่มนมกินอาหารเช้านะใจแล้ว
แล้วอ่ะเธอ
คิด
อะไร
คิดว่าตอนกลางวันกินอะไร
ออนตอนกลางวันไหมกลางวันก็คือประมาณตอน
เที่ยง
รักตอนเที่ยงครูฟ้าสวยกูฟ้าคิดคิด
กินอะไร
กินอะไรครูฟ้าคิดว่า
มี Choice ค่ะโหมี Choice อะไรบ้าง
มีมีผัดไทยอ๋ออ๋อมีสองถอยใช่ไหมครูฟ้า้
โป้ไทยแล้วก็อีกหนึ่งช้อยราคา B
อะไร
pizza โอ๋
คิดๆ
pizza
ครูฟ้าฟ้าคิดว่าตอนกลางวัน
แต่น้ำตอนกลางวันคือฟ้าจะกินอะไร
กินอะไร
ครูฟ้าคิดว่า
ครูฟ้าจะกิน
พิซซ่าน้อ
พิซซ่าแล้วไม่รู้ฟ้าคิดไหมว่าครูฟ้าจะกิน
พิซซ่า
กับใคร
คู่ฟ้าจะกินพิซซ่ากับคุณแม่อ๋อเบื่อกิน
ตอนเช้าจะไปหามีคุณแม่แล้วก็มีซ่าครูฟ้า
คุณแม่ pizza ช่วยกินที่อ่ะอ้าวคุณแม่ครู
ฟ้าอันนี้กูป๊ากรรมคุณแร่ใช้กูฟ้าจะกิน
พิซซ่ากับคุณแม่แล้วรู้ฟ้าจะกินพิซซ่ากับ
คุณแม่ที่ไหน
ครูฟ้าจะกินพิซซ่ากับคุณแม่ที่ร้าน pizza
โห
ไม่ได้กินพิซซ่ากับคุณแม่ที่บ้านไม่ใช่
ไม่กินที่บ้านไปกินที่ร้าน pizza
ร้าน pizza โหร้าน pizza นะอยู่ที่ไหนคะ
ร้าน pizza อยู่ที่
ห้างห้าง
อยู่ข้างอะไร
เซ็นทรัล
เซ็นทรัลโต
เซ็นทรัลที่พัทยา Intro พัทยาใช่ไหมคะ
เนี่ยคือห้างนะคะเอาครูฟ้าฟ้าจะไปกิน
พิซซ่ากับคุณแม่แม่กูฟ้าแล้วก็คุณแม่สี
ฟ้าแล้วก็แม่ทำไมกูบาสกับคุณแม่ที่ห้าง
นายหานี่เลยเซ็นทรัลพัทยานะคะ
ชายแล้วครูฟ้าจะดื่มอะไรกับพิซซ่าคะก็ครู
ฟ้าเนี่ยกินพิซซ่ามีพิซซ่าแล้วจะไม่ต้อง
กินพิซซ่าแล้วคู่ฟ้า
จะดื่มอะไร
ครูฟ้าก็คิดว่าครูฟ้าจะดื่ม
เป๊ปซี่ 5 เอาดื่มเป๊ปซี่กินแล้วครูฟ้า
ใส่น้ำแข็งไหมคะเป๊ปซี่ใส่น้ำแข็งไหมใส่
หรือว่าไม่ใส่ไอ้น้ำแข็งอ่ะใส่ง่ายๆ
เย็นๆเป๊บซี่เย็นดื่มเป๊ปซี่แล้วก็กิน
พิซซ่าด้วยกันต้องหาด้วยค่ะโอเคนะโอเค
อร่อยนาตาย
ผู้หญิงคิดไหมว่าครูหญิงกินอะไรครูหญิง
คิดว่าตอนกลางวันเนี่ยนะคะน่าจะครูหญิง
เนี่ยจะกิน
ไม่กินก๋วยเตี๋ยวแล้วน้องร้านก๋วยเตี๋ยว
iya จะกิน
ข้าวมันไก่ค่ะ
ๆข้าวมันไก่
โง่
สายกินข้าวมันไก่แต่คิดว่ากินที่บ้าน
[เพลง]
กินที่บ้านที่คอนโดมิเนียมอะเนาะกินบ้าน
น้อง pizza ทรายน้องบีมากเลยค่ะต้องนัก
เรียนล่ะนักเรียนคิดไหมนักเรียนจะกินอะไร
คือ
ที่ไหนที่ไหนนั่งกินกับใครอ่ะใครอ่ะอ่ะ
อาหาร
เกาะถ้าคอมเม้นท์บอกเราได้ว่ากินเวลากี่
โมง
หาก็คอมเม้นท์บอกเราได้น้องวีดีโอนี้เรา
สองคนก็ต้องไปก่อนนะคะถ้าเจอกันใหม่
วิดีโอหน้า
บ๊ายบายสวัสดีค่าบ